une production du studio sfr
bienvenue sans filtre le podcast on se
croise les jambes comme ça un petit peu
trop agressivement à défaut de même ce
prix est complètement
ou est ce que l'on fait on parle de
notre vie nos actes et dans le fond est
ce qu'on veut de ce qu'on veut de
n'importe quoi de la pluie ou du bondage
ph quentin avec moi de me plante
si vous voulez entendre plus de nous
deux
tergiverser quand on vient là parlent ou
les micros qui
[Musique]
on a une page piquionne ou est-ce que
après chaque podcasts ont fait encore
moins de films ce qu'on parle de la
consume promet d'avoir puis aussi où
elle se remet tous nos podcasts au
moment où est ce qu on les enregistre
donc vous voulez avoir accès en primeur
aller sur notre pétrole la déception va
être dans la
déception le lien pardon
dans la description du podcast cette
semaine dès cette semaine on reçoit
louis audet gosselin qui est le
directeur scientifique et stratégique du
centre de prévention de la
radicalisation menant à la violence et
aux historiens et sociologues une
formation et un doctorat en sociologie à
l'uqam je trouve que s'intéresse
justement ces dynamiques le de de
respiration puissamment qu'est-ce que
question sont les causes qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont les moyens de les prévenir
des moines y ait de de reach out en
personne en bon français une personne de
notre entourage qui se radicalise en ce
moment a fait honneur à sa mort parce
que je pense que c'est un phénomène qui
tend même observable dans la société
par rapport aux éditions le parler de
l'accueil vite par l'atelier des gens
qui clament elles vont adhérer à
certaines
certaine pensée plus radicale plus
extrêmes pour même à revenir à la
violence mais on parle de rascal son
attelage que ce soit religieux ça peut
d'extrême droite extrême gauche
je pense que c'est important de
comprendre ces phénomènes le savoir le
reconnaître savoir surtout comment un
petit peu on peut
réparer les pompes essayer de contrer ce
phénomène qui à mon nom scientifique
d'observateurs un phénomène qui
grandissent un petit qui est un vrai
problème de société donc pour ce qu'on
voulait discuter du sujet je pense que
c'est intéressant je les maisons avec la
polarisation des opinions y la
radicalisation qui se crée
définitivement de plus en plus donc
avant de vous laisser à cette
conversation là on va les remercier nos
commentateurs
le podcast est présenté par ce choc ce
chien qui se
torche à qui sait les fournisseurs de bi
pnc caribéenne
ça vous permet de changer virtuellement
votre location sur internet donc ça ça
peut permettre ces maisons vous une
série ou un film que vous savez qui est
sortie si le aller sur un netflix aux
autres billets pas disponibles sadi une
pas disponible dans votre location sa
musique est qu'ils disposaient mettons
ailleurs mais pas au québec sauf si tu
resteras - lolo une fois j'étais dans un
autre pays six mois avant de le nord du
coup toujours mon petit biophysique pour
disponibles imagine la panique que j'ai
vécu s'il avait surchargé les pn
j'aurais pu écouter mon petit a fait sa
manucure puis un vpn aussi ça sert à
naviguer sur des réseaux publics de
façon plus sécuritaire donc par exemple
si vous êtes souvent sur la route que
vous êtes dans des ouailles faille à
gauche à droite un vpn le vpn sur ce
choc en fait vous permettre d'être plus
sécuritaire dans votre connexion si vous
êtes un étudiant qu'elle est souvent
dans des cafés même principe sur chaque
offre une énorme promotion pour vous si
vous vous voulez l'utiliser le code
promo qu'on a c'est le centre en mo
tenez vous bien pour l'heure ce qui s'en
vient que si vous êtes assis rester
assis si vous êtes debout assise et vous
êtes assis couché vous si vous êtes dans
votre voiture arrêtez vous sur le côté
qu'est le code promo sans filtre en un
mot pour 83% draper et 3 mois gratuits
bac acier vous le donne québec pour
pouvoir changer virtuellement
d'adressent et pour pouvoir naviguer
tation plus sécuritaire ce choc allez
voir le site dans la déception de
podcasts utile que promo sans fil en un
mot ce chan chan le podcast de cette
semaine et présenté par mon ami chez
mindscape note que j'ai deviné nos
préférés et qui vient de sortir le ultra
premium collection qui est un
rassemblement de tout plein de produits
pour se nettoyer sentir bon s'hydrater
on a un d eux on a un body wash pour la
douche on a 2 ans non shampoing
revitalisant on a un peu d'esprit
hydratante et un les bandes d'hommes de
terrain de porto libre vous y prendre de
peau sèche seul en face entre dans
partout et puis j'aime l'esprit le miz
amis comme vous avez jamais vu quelqu'un
sait ce prix vous avez jamais vu
quelqu'un jouer ce prix qui maintenant
j'ai la peau hydratée je me sens bien et
bien tous les produits inscrits qui sont
là le jeu les écossais y est c'est la
même odeur incroyable dans leurs
produits le shampooing conditionneurs le
body wash alors médecin à votre dossier
tevez sur des projets censés rebond
d'être d'être optimal pour une vie
optimale on en compte trois mois je
pense c'est sans fil 20% de rabais sur
eux et le shipping gratuit le gp ni
gratuit sur cette collection l'oeil sur
n'importe quel produit même ce quel que
soit le package 4.0 le culte le snood
package alors allez fournie sur leur
site et fait mount comment comptez vous
recommande même script
je pense vous serez pas les duperies yes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
super donc bienvenu merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci pour
l'invitation c'est vraiment un super
sujet qui est la radicalisation un sujet
qui est on ne peut plus actuelle en ce
moment puis je voudrais qu'on commence
la conversation parce que moi je suis je
suivais gagnent puis dans le mouvement
vegan que le mouvement des droits des
animaux il ya de la radicalisation mais
un des aspects
j'ai envie de dire principaux d'aider
des activistes radicaux
c'est qu'ils savent pas qu'ils sont
radicaux puis que le creusement le hero
world le dans ces milieux là où est-ce
que tu mentionnes à quelqu'un qui est
radical ça choque pissant sacré de la
tension qu'est ce qui est à la nature de
cette espèce de désir de s'éloigner du
mot radical puis du de cette
terminologie le c'est un terme qui est
vraiment
péjoratif c'est pas est-ce que personne
qui le revendique ce comme tous ces
termes là extrême droite
radical extrémistes personne très peu
qui vont leur verdict et aucun cas ça va
de fait ça va être un espèce de
provocation
c'est parce que tout le monde considère
que qui sont très raisonnables puis la
vidéo vraiment de problème c'est que
c'est juste normal c'est naturel de
penser sauf que si les autres sont pas
d'accord avec eux ou les trous vous
trouvez que service bas c'est un peu
leur problème c'est un peu ce qui est
délicat avec sais
c'est pas la seule chose qui est délicat
mais il ya beaucoup c'est un élément
vraiment délicat
de faire accepter aux gens qui ont
peut-être dans ce que tu étais un peu
trop loin ou peut-être que je considère
pas du tout les autres points de vue ou
tété mode d'action sont pas acceptable
socialement son violeur ou seront dix
ans ça va avoir des conséquences
néfastes
donc ça c'est tout un travail avec la
faire avec les gens qui est qui est pas
évident donc
c'est un peu une caractéristique de
beaucoup de gens radicaliser ou dans un
parcours de radicalisation ceux qui
pensent avoir trouvé quelque chose que
la majorité a pas compris et que bon le
i ce ont envoyé leur désir de
transformation sociale est vraiment
important puis
ils peuvent pas accepter leur que
de
2,2 contradictions de nuances de point
de vue de se remettre en question c'est
pour ça que c'est très difficile de
discuter avec quelqu'un qui est pas un
parcours de radicalisation puis bien que
là le spectre de la radicalisation et
grands il ya quand même certains aspects
qui sont
catégoriques des choses qu'on peut de
façon externe évaluée comme étant dans
la direction la radicalisation et en
radicaliser enfant sait de quoi on parle
quand on parle de ce parcours le pc m'a
piqué ce qu'ils sont
les les clés de lecture pour quelqu'un
qui voit un autre personne soit sombre
et où
c'est c'est pas évident parce que c'est
plus que d'adopter des idées qui sont
marginales ou qui sont plus extrême que
les autres ce ne soit le le sentiment
que met-on l'extrémisme ces lettres au
boulot de l'espèce de spect puis que si
on est capable un milieu c'est correct
pas vraiment historiquement ya de
longues en fait avancer les choses en
étant radicaux en état le norad
tout le monde devrait voter comme ça
les esclavages c'est pas une bonne idée
les trucs qui à l'époque était vraiment
radicaux on parle pas de ça quand on
parle du parcours de radicalisation
vance extrémistes c'est qualitativement
autre chose on parle de d'un parcours où
on va
adhérer à des idées acquis qui clivent
nous contre eux il ya un groupe de ton
d'élus ou de personnes qui peuvent faire
partie des bons et un groupe et demi et
un groupe composé et temps qui reçoit
cette division là
puis il ya la volonté d'agir contre
les on compte le groupe ceux qui sont
perçus comme des ennemis donc quand on
ne sait si dimension la
belle on peut parler vraiment un
parcours de radicalisation c'est donc
que qui peut mener ou pas à la violence
mais c'est ses danses et ses paramètres
là qu'on peut voir de l'extérieur
a pris mais objectivement de son micro
mais un jour dans l'ignorance lui mais
que parcours de radicalisation quand on
considère pour les points de vue opposés
quand on se considère qu'il ya des
catégories qui sont de gens qui sont
néfastes sont mauvais qui doivent être
combattus
non
un
autre koala qui peut être montréal où on
peut imaginer des fois cette catégorie
l'europe arlit où on parle de groupes
mais c'est vraiment une opposition
envers un groupe qui est vu comme étant
une menace
j'ai regardé la documentation sur votre
site web ses pieds
le les causes de la radicalisation ou
les bousculer
les motifs à se radicaliser sont
vraiment variable en fait en une
infinité presse que finalement on peut
être que c'est beau presque un peu tôt
lundi oui donc
mais finalement on se rend compte qu'il
ya toujours des traits femmes en commun
qui se rejoignent m
on voit un peu les traits de l'extrême
gauche extrême droite se tissent des
crimes et finalement on finit toujours
par un peu ressembler à l'autre mais
aussi
tactique dans une manière de procéder ou
ouais c'est ça toutes les idéologies
peuvent mener à la radicalisation
peuvent mener à la violence par les deux
véganisme on peut parler d'extrême
droite de mouvements religieux
est bon il faut comprendre un peu les
différents les différences entre ces
tendances l'appui il ya des différences
fondamentales mais dans le cc dans le
parcours il ya des traits communs il ya
des bons travailler avec les facteurs de
vulnérabilité
puis des facteurs de protection qui
souvent se ressemblent donc on va parler
souvent de sentiment de marginalisation
d'un sentiment d'exclusion ça c'est
vraiment un
facteur de vulnérabilité majeur insiste
un sentiment c'est pas toujours vrai
donc mettons déjà
dans l'adhésion des jeunes djihadistes
par exemple occidentaux au mouvement
djihadiste y avait beaucoup de
sentiments de d'être rejetée comme
musulmans ne pas pouvoir faire partie de
la société comme musulmans dans les
mouvements d'extrême droite on reçoit
avoir l'impression que on est menacée
dans notre identité par les changements
sociaux pour les transformations sûr
économiquement culturellement
que l'immigration que différents
phénomènes sociaux vont être les façons
nous menacer notre identité c'est pas
toujours vrai on a pas meilleur jeudi
ressentiment le ce sentiment les vrais
piliers dit au coeur il ya donc facteurs
de vulnérabilité au plan personnel
souvent des gens qui on va aborder des
enjeux identitaires personnel des
problèmes avec leurs familles qui vont
chercher un espèce de cirque social
c'est serré il est au viage bien souvent
ces couleurs font le besoin
d'appartenance un gros trou ce groupe
lucky qui t'accueille libre et ouverte
seppi qui quitteraient pas toute la
famille que je voudrais qu'on porte en
attendant il ya cette dimension là qui
est qui est beaucoup présent dans la
radicalisation
faire partie d'un groupe
c'est vraiment une famille de
substitution le des fois c'est très
clair d'autres fois c'est plus diffus
il y a
il ya aussi le sentiment de vouloir
participer à quelque chose de plus grand
pour transformer la société d'être utile
il s'en tire vraiment mis à contribution
leur façon utile ça c'est vraiment
important aussi pour dimensionner tantôt
le
gros enjeu de société qui ont marqué
l'avancement des causes sociales comme
la femme esclavage le droit de vote des
femmes puis ces mouvements-là qui était
perçu comme un l'encontre de la tendance
de la société à l'époque
est-ce que ça peut servir
des gens radicaliser
comme exemple pour justifier leur
comportement
puis si oui de quelle façon est ce que
ces choses-là sont différentes parce
qu'on parlait tantôt ça prend un ennemi
s'apprend puis à ce moment là il y en
avait des ennemis l'ennemi c'est la
suprématie blanche l'ennemi s'était
c'était là le sexisme puis
c'est quoi la différence entre ses
jambes parce que mettons moi je vois
quelqu'un qui est prenons garde ont
l'exemple du droit des animaux qui
devient super extrême par l'endroit des
animaux qui les grosses manifs allez les
bleus cage de camion qui transporte des
animaux ce genre de chose le même les
actions illégales de s'infiltrer dans
toutes ces choses là donc on a vu passer
mes hôtes y voit la cause animale comme
où ils pensent voir la cause animale la
même façon que par exemple les noirs
voyait la cause des noirs ou même tout
le monde qui s'opposait au wall
esclavage à l'époque comme c'est quoi la
différence ces choses là c'est assez
délicat parce que le yoyo pas une
différence cependant rp ou un taux est
l'exemple des mouvements des droits des
animaux et est assez intéressant parce
que
c'est une position qui est comme on peut
être d'accord ou pas mais qui
légitimerait défendable le mouvement
antispéciste bon
radicale les gens très convaincus vont
pas accepter aucun argument sur la
viande éthique ou croco coincé non non
non ainsi si ma coque personnellement
c'est une
position qui est absolument légitime
au sens le pari qu'on fait c'est que la
société québécoise actuelle
et démocratiques et les espaces où
les idées légitimes peuvent s'exprimer
si on accepte que il ya des règles il ya
des espaces on peut l'exprimer que la
violence c'est pas quelque chose que
collectivement on va on va accepter et
que
faut accepter quand on se met dans ce
débat leur démocratique on va peut-être
pas gagné que la main les gens sont
seront pas nécessairement d'accord qu'il
faut accepter aussi que les autres
puissent cheminer de leur façon qu'on
peut essayer de les convoyer qu'on peut
faire des actions
nous ont le new collègues policiers
seront pas d'accord mais on se préoccupe
même pas s'avancer légal ou pas c'est
plutôt 2
de la violence dont il ya des actions
qui peuvent être dérangeante qui peuvent
peu déranger les autres on peut les
achats les les agacer c'est pas vraiment
un problème c'est pas manifestation
silencieuse devant le canada gauche sera
incité une n'importe quoi c'est pour
c'est pas de la radicalisation menant à
la violence qu on a mis ça dans notre
titre pour ce que c'est ça qu'on veut
près qu'on veut prévenir parce qu'on
veut pas prévenir toutes les formes de
radicalisation
c'est pas on veut pas être on n'est pas
une police d'idées
de toute façon il ya des formes comme
tout c'est tantôt il ya des formes de
radicalisation qui amène réellement un
changement social parce que ça prend un
gros coup de barre à des moments pour
créer le changement oui c'est ça
personne n'avait dit essayer de
deux d'abolir la monarchie quelque part
ben on aurait probablement pas de
démocratie on peut questionner ce que le
niveau de violence qui ont été
accueillis était employé mai puis c'est
pour ça qu'on dit notre approche
fonctionne au québec on prétend pas que
ça va fonctionner ailleurs si on est en
syrie vous voulez manifester pour la
démocratie en syrie puis
l'alarmé du cerf dessus mais on n'est
pas là pour juger si vous décidez de
prendre les armes si vous décidez de
parce que c'est
on est conscient que les résistances
armées à des à des régimes autoritaires
on est vraiment dans le ton du il peut y
avoir des éléments radicaux extrémistes
dans ccfa bellion là mais le fait de se
rebeller contre un mouvement autoritaire
nous on constate que ça fait
comme tu dis c'est un contexte du québec
il n'y a pas d'idée qui persécute et les
innocents ce qu'il ne vote qui a le
droit de défendre n'importe quelle idée
sur la place publique sans qu'ils aient
sans consensus en quoi que ce soit mais
prétend pas que c'est parfait il y
aurait beaucoup de gens qui se plaignent
certains groupements on parle de nessma
le même droit de parole
il ya
du racisme
sexisme
les préjugés des billets au sein même
des institutions soit c'est vrai il ya
un travail à faire transformer les
institutions les rendre plus
démocratique plus ouverte mais on peut
exprimer la plupart des idées
qu'on veut si ça respect certain cadre
démocratique puis de vivre ensemble donc
il ya des idées qui
par leur énonciation son annulation donc
si vous voulez créer un parti politique
nazie pie dire que l'on va gagner les
élections ont pacifiquement puis établir
un régime dictatorial pacifiquement
née dans autre chose donc mais il ya des
toujours des enjeux fondamentaux
légitime sur l'identité sur la culture
somine qui peuvent être accueillis qu'on
peut discuter c'est quoi être québécois
c'est quoi
c'est la place la région la société tout
soit on peut tout à faire débattre les
positions sont 100 soldats
radhika sont maintenant à la violence la
violence souvent que vous voulez
prévenez apprend qu'elle forme et on
sait ça va vraiment dans le coup tout un
spectacle dans la vie à la limite on
parle de
le contexte de création du cpmb le 2015
le son était dans l'air
l'état islamique en syrie puis les gens
qui voulaient partir ou qui ont vu
qu'ils ont commis des attentats on était
dans une violence et de terrorisme
en
manquant sa commande sous la violence de
ce mandat prend les armes qui a sauté
débat
tout haut niveau ça peut être dans les
dix corps ou si doc les discours haineux
ça c'est une forme de violence
du vandalisme aussi cette forme de
violence surtout quand ces quatre
connotation injurieuse par exemple vous
avant d'aller sur un lieu de culte vous
visez l'ensemble de la communauté a
comme sentiment d'insécurité donc c'est
une atteinte au sentiment de sécurité de
la population d'une partie de la
population ou d'une personne
suspecte puis évidemment il ya des
niveaux de gravités look sont différents
mais ça vaut de ce poisson bon assez
large il ya vraiment ça va des discours
berling aussi dans beaucoup
de magasins pendant que cette forme là
même où beaucoup évolué
c'est assez connu le coeur en ligne
beaucoup de discours peu plus que en
personne les gens se permettent plus de
dire n'importe quoi et l'alignement il
ya tout un contexte où on va on est dans
les cercles compense un peu privé donc
les jeunes relance un peu de discours
viola mais aussi de l'intimidation soit
qu'ils aient des conséquences remarques
real va beaucoup d'entre les acteurs nus
que la violence en général
j'imagine que les groupes privés et il
fit sauter je me sens comme le terreau
fertile pour la réalisation nautique est
facile justement de se trouver un peu un
sentiment d'appartenance à un groupe
justement pi2 qui partagent un délice
des plis finalement on veut plus en plus
crus dans cette ligne de pensée le sait
comme l'ensemble de la vie sociale de
plus en plus l'espace en ligne fait
partie de notre vie fait partie notre
réseau social de ces deux rencontres en
ligne des espaces on va rencontrer
discuter avec des jeunes de partout dans
le monde qui nous ressemblent un peu
qu'ils partagent des idées sur des
éleveurs on peut ne jamais les
rencontrer c'est la même chose pour les
la radicalisation
c est le pendant la pandémie s'est
accentuée parce que les gens sont encore
plus isolé le sentiment d'isolement
d'isolement social c'est un gros facteur
de vulnérabilité le pour la
radicalisation
dans la violence donc on est un seul ou
en plus ou moins seulement voteraient
pas des bons contacts de contacts de
qualité dans son entourage mais à 3 des
gens qui pensent un peu comme nous en
ligne qui peuvent être à l'autre bout du
monde bon ça donne du réconfort on a
envie de passer plus de temps là
toute une culture de de la gratification
sur les réseaux sociaux donc il est là
et qui a donc enfin commentaires
un peu fâché j'ai pleinement de gamme ce
qui répond noyage d'accord je d'accord
le plus important cinq hommes valides
est d'accord il ya venu vraiment ça
beaucoup dimension mais c'est ça les
algorithmes aussi qu'ils nous avaient
souvent voir des discours qu'on tire ça
parce qu'on consulte donc on
est propice à s'enfermer dans des
groupes discret un peu sa propre réalité
sur mesure maintenant oui oui vous avez
vous pouvez avoir accès un tas d'idées
d'action de penser que tous savaient
même pas qu'ils étaient donc
des contenus des trucs qui se passent
dans un autre pays que vous connaissez
plus - mais bon ça vient vous chercher
parce que
il ya une réalité qui vous ressemble
nous allons j'en ai un sur mon facebook
qui est un que je connaissais une
connaissance le développeur année qui
kim a ajouté dans une genre de
conversation de deux groupes le thé que
tu peux ajouter autant de cultures
puis il fait juste un vague idée d
information le thé des trucs goût par
rapport à la cave le rapport a été au
gouvernement du sud seppi
s'est dit vraiment des trucs
conspirationnistes le tir passe juste
postes créés en critiquant le
gouvernement c'est vraiment aider
d'aider des fausses informations sur les
vaccins surtout ce type i je me dis ah
yoye titre golog
il vit pas dans le même monde que moi
noté sa réalité rendu complètement
autres le t2 10 qui envoie là dedans
clairement
on lit pas les mêmes journaux ou en t on
s'informe peau même place on essaye
vraiment l'oeil et c'est vraiment créer
son son monde
sait qu'un canadair un univers de pensée
extrémiste
on va
considérer les autres discours comme
dément son jeune amant puis ça vient
valider notre pointu si on essaie de
nous convaincre si on nous attaque si on
nous dit vous avez tort c'est faux ce
que vous dites vautours sont pas bonnes
ça vient pouvait que les médias qui sont
contre vous c'est vraiment cette
dynamique là très difficile d'en sortir
de
le percevoir un bon point vu quand on
est
quand on a atteint un certain seuil de
l'adhésion
à une idéologie le
pigiste cdj idéologie le
jeu des conspirationnistes le même
sillage de ces
images in que depuis la pandémie puis
deux puis surtout entré récemment c'est
comme ça doit être la forme que vous
voyez plus le site ainsi ne sais pas si
on le voit le plus - comme directeur
scientifique j'ai pas accès à la ligne
no 2 je sais pas exactement c'est quoi
les thèmes c'est sûr que c'est quelque
chose qui est arrivée façon beaucoup
plus importante qu'avant
sais si c'est parce que c'est la cause
sociale centrale vraiment c'est sida
nouvelle à tous les jours depuis deux
heures on n'est que là dedans donc ce
qui était les mouvements marginaux à 20
parce que
cinq cités tout prix de conspiration là
c'est le ca existait avant
bay et s mobiliser sur des enjeux qui
était relativement privée où se faisait
vacciner ou pas vos enfants bon faut
avoir des discussions un peu plus corsé
des fois avec vos proches et les
maladies se pose pas de n'importe quoi
mais ça restait quand même s'il n'y
avait pas de crise s'il n'y avait pas
des crozes épidémie de rougeole qui
faisait urgent d'aller vacciner tout le
monde
maintenant donc là mais là on est
vraiment là dedans c'est donc
c'est devenu un mouvement politique
forte les décisions les principales
décisions politiques sont venus
confronter ses idées là il ya beaucoup
de
militants qui ont voulu exploiter la
crise
beaucoup de militants d'extrême droite
par exemple qui sont investis dans ces
théories du complot là est-ce qu'ils y
croient ou potes c'est ce qui les
instrumentalisent ça dépend des gens
mais il y avait des jeunes
font de complotiste le dans l'extrême
droite en général
donc il ya beaucoup de bons jeunes
entrepreneurs politiques extrêmement spi
utilise la crise comme n'importe quelle
crise je les mouvements des moments de
crise est toujours professeur
l'extrémisme vous êtes entrepreneur
politique tout dire de l'industrie
profite qu'aux entrepreneurs pas au sens
monétaire mais au sens où ils cherchent
ils ont une cause plus ou moins défini
puis selon l'actualité ils vont orienter
l'antico pour recruter déjà ou pour
avoir des adhérents on tourne donc on a
vu des plus anciennes figures le 2 août
à l'extrême droite québécoise de quêtes
annexes et actif lors de la grande
manifestation contre l'immigration à
2016-2017
qui oserait appropriées sur le discours
aux sandales puis avec
un espèce de discours populiste général
le peuple et zélé est en nous mais on
nous manipule
donc il faut faut casser le système soit
et ça attire quand même pas mal de monde
dans la cage vide à cause de la crise à
cause d isolement de la peur
je l'aiderai
un des critères ou du moins des critères
d'évaluation de pour essayer de saisir
si quelqu'un dans notre entourage
sur est en train de se faire radicaliser
y avait un aspect que je trouvais
intéressant puis qui s'appliquait
principalement à ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui c'était la personne se sent
victime du monde entier de plaine à fort
prix ça me faisait penser à un
reportage sur les camionneurs en ce
moment là tu as well as quelques
semaines fait que même au début de cette
histoire avant qu'on en soit rendu ou
est ce qu on en est rendu aujourd'hui ou
est ce qu'il y avait un monsieur kim qui
était absolument convaincu en sortant
son cellulaire que
tout les noms qui apparaissait cas calé
sur blue tout les noms qui apparaissent
là c'était des gens qui avaient été
vaccinées puis lui était persuadé que
c'était son blue doute que les gens
vaccinés dans le fond puis je ne mettais
pas sur la réflexion avant même de
commencer à lire la documentation sur
leurs difficultés leur radicalisation en
préparation au procter d'aujourd'hui je
vais te passer de commentaires je me dis
si ce monsieur le pense à chaque matin
de se réveiller en étant en tabarnak
contre le monde entier parce que parce
qu'il y ait rien de plus intrusif que
quand hitler tchèque ton ciel bleu de la
liste des gens vaccinés à côté de toi
qui se font pas niée par le 3 par le par
le bluetooth puis je me disais ça doit
être invivable être dans semaines cette
loque constamment de penser que la
société au complet et constamment comme
toi que tu es le seul à voir la lumière
le train mais c'est la preuve qu'on va
voir au centre aussi c'est que les gens
qui sont dans un parcours de
radicalisation oui ils peuvent être
dangereux
il y aura un enjeu de sécurité
là des seuls peuvent être aussi
détestable pour l'ensemble de la société
mais s'est déjà souvent qu'ils vont
avoir besoin d'être les premiers à
souffrir de ça dans les dents les
mouvements conspirationnistes vraiment
ça a été documentée et un service yeux
de l'anxiété de peur qui amène à un des
grâces et que ses théories là parce que
ça donne une explication cohérente
je vous apporte tout de tout les
problèmes mais cette explication l'aef
est tellement aussi peur que ça renforce
l'action était donc les gens se
retrouvent coincés là dedans et et puis
ce bel exemple que tu donnes et et par
là parce que
c'est quand même vrai que les compagnies
technologies sont intrusive l'école de
danse ont déjà donc il ya un fondement
qui est légitime dans cette part le
savent eux d'imaginer la direction que
les compagnies des technologies prennent
en ce moment ça peut faire peur c'est
effectivement ce bain sur le talent de
reconnaissance faciale on parle de plein
d'éléments
tous arrivés arriver à tout le monde
dira
avons l'impression que les gens disent
quelque chose puis l'as brécey et
regarde puis une annonce de ce qui passe
c'est pas démontré que c'est vrai que ce
soit des circonstances de leur match ça
arrive
toutes les fois qu'ils sont la semaine
on a cherché nourriture pour chats tête
on n'a rien on le cherche et puis on
s'en souvient piscine enterrée ce sont
conversation mais c'est des choses qui
techniquement serait passé virons ton
c'est pire voit dans d'autres pays
autoritaires où il y aurait des mesures
il ya des situations pendant le plus
intrusive la technologie donc s'il ya un
fondement qui est qui est légitime à
cette peur le cette colère le c'est
comme
le défi c'est d'amener jal exprimé de
façon
pro sociales drass et trouver des
solutions dès maintenant iman avec soit
mort basée sur les faits puis qu'ils
soient qui soient constructifs pour
l'argent de la société n'ont pas quitté
les vous qui désigne des ennemis à
abattre
puis c'est quoi d'autres signaux que
quelqu'un est en train de tomber dans ce
il y avait un musulman je pense fait les
allemands cécile isolement seulement
ça touche beaucoup de jeunes on convoque
le bal en somme on voit que le bassin de
et potentiel est très large
ça va souvent être une combinaison de
facteurs il ya pas un il n'y a pas de
c'est toujours délicat d'amener ça parce
que on veut pas amener les gens à faire
du profilage donc c'est pas ouais tu te
convertis à changer de sac d'amis
tu fais cela faire
attention tu es juges me mettre
surveiller ça ça risque
d'accélérer parcours d'éducation donc
des changements sociaux du changement
d'idée s'intéresser de façon des fois un
petit peuple
obsessionnelle sur un sujet c'est un peu
normal surtout chez les jeunes c'est
quelque chose que nous sommes passés de
remettre en question mais ressemble la
société de vouloir ses moyens lui aussi
est
un passage presqu'obligé pour les jeunes
une histoire
c'est quand même courait puis c'est pas
ça peut amener certaines personnes à
commettre des
actes requis qui vont regretter plus
tard
en tant que tel
questionnement qui peut être légitime
donc c'est ça on veut pas dire ouais ce
que je t'ai bonnes cases
attention c'est
c'est vraiment dalle
la ligne il faut radical au centre et
sert aussi à
rassurer les gens si vous avez des xix
un proche l'équipe s'inquiète
ouvertement les théories du complot le
comprenez le 5 g
si si si ça vous procure pour cissé
c'est noté il ya moyen d'appeler puis de
voir bon c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire c'est tout remarque un proche il
commence à sombrer on pourra comparer
les informations un petit peu de lettres
pour comment gérer la situation s'est
globalement les les trois classes et
c'est d'essayer de maintenir le contact
autant que possible de ne pas confronter
le directement c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment dans une démarche extremis la
vie ça sert à rien de confronter les
idées se débattent la pizza piotta si on
le fait c'est vraiment sur des points
précis avec des faits le ramener un fait
si vous avez quelque chose de simple
non regardez l'information que non ça
c'est pas vrai
pour laisser la personne cheminée elle
même la m on peut partager des
informations dans la team métis de façon
vraiment pas intrusive ça c'est pas
jamais entré dans contre confrontation
parce que ces registres avis le problème
wen dans presque tous les cas c'est ce
qui fait pis c'est au niveau personnel
mais si vos niveaux plus large aussi on
le voit que les les débats sociaux
souvent très polarisée
tous sont des petits politiciens des
gens des médias qui est de faire un peu
de capital en qui va
bon on le fait que la pandémie au site
il ya vraiment des
les adhérents des théories
conspirationnistes sont souvent
présentés comme des imbéciles comme
décidé ça ça
tous ses discours publics là ça
contribue à renforcer leur mal là le
sentiment d'appartenance le sentiment de
tout faire flamand pour que cette
personne là que je faisais question
parce que c'est ce que du monde qui
écoutent sérieusement on le presque tous
dans leur entourage quelqu'un qui attend
à certaines théories ou kiki qui s'isole
de plus en plus avec dans certains
groupes se fait si finalement tout faire
pour que
contrer cet isolement de ses personnels
de garder une présence
autant que possible des fois c'est pas
possible du procès comme cc physiquement
c'est bandant émotionnellement puis
c'est vraiment de reynal donc à ton on
sait plus quoi faire on peut demander de
l'aide là il ya des ressources le sens
dans l'yonne il ya il y en a d'autres
mais
essaie aussi de garder le lien au plan
personnel qui s'intéressait à la
personne plutôt que toujours là les mots
sujet que jugés dangereux c'est
quelqu'un amis que j'avais depuis
longtemps
par les souvenirs communs que j'avais
des intérêts communs
ce procès a mené la personne a changé
d'ère aller ailleurs quelque chose qui
existe parce que ça s'engager dans une
cause qui est
extremis qui est qui peut être violente
c'est très très simple c'est
vraiment une charge constante parce
qu'on se tape c'est ce qu'on voit dans
les gens qui sont sortis beaucoup qui
sont sortis de ce n'était plus tenable
d'être toujours toujours en compression
d'être toujours toujours en mobilisation
l'impermanence man et ses
volontés de lâcher prise puis c'est ça
mais c'est
moi moi pour dans l'exemple du véganisme
et de la cause animale
il fallut que au début j'étais vraiment
vraiment convaincu et un temps sauf
qu'il a fallu que je laisse aller parce
que si tu acceptes que par exemple les
gens qui consomment la viande sont des
meurtriers de masse tout le monde autour
de toi et des meurtriers de masse des
parents ta mère des amis tout le monde
habitable on l'a fait que tu d'haïti
tout des meurtriers de masse le avec
comment tu veux vivre dans ce monde là
quand tu te lèves le matin puis que tout
le monde autour de toi et des moeurs
trimestre le carnet faut que tu que tu
laisses aller parce que c'est la seule h
le ccc c'est tout ce que ton esprit si
tu vois le monde à travers ses prismes
le constamment
ces gens là qui ont égalisé peu importe
la cause c'est comme tout est analysé à
travers c'était gris le lieu
exact puis j'ai une amie qui au début de
la vaccination n'était pas pour l'idée
de la vaccination obligatoire qui passe
par vaccinale puis était quand même
ardemment contre lalanne avait peur du
vaccin karima puis on est en réalisant
que sa peur du vaccin puis le fait
qu'elle n'avait pas sa place vaccinale
faisait qu'à se réveiller le matin peas
et et je sais qu'ils occupent et son
esprit parce qu' après palais dans un
resto à pouvait pas aller
voir telle personne dans un cinéma après
pas faire ses activités lopy était
préoccupé par le par le seul fait qu'ils
n'étaient pas vaccinés en
faut que je le laisse à l'effet que le
prix là le faire sur deux soit vaccinée
puis après ça le lendemain de son
premier maxi est il passé pu terminer le
reste est une étape à fond c'était
terminé je peux comprendre qu'il faut
voir mais qui passe par dessus tu es des
valeurs et des principes mais quand tu
réalises que tu aimes ça occupe toutes
les pensées ce n'est que du négatif au
comme je passe par dessus
ce 5e aussi qu'ils aient vécu
particulier sur un geste le saint géran
l'enjeu c'est plus qu'assez l'adhésion à
une idéologie le qui veut tout
transformer c'est extrêmement difficile
de le sortir parce que c'est aussi
admettre que pendant des années vous
foncer dans le mur
vietor vous avez gaspiller ce sens dès
lors il ya vraiment c'est un deuil à
faire puis comme on le disait ce sera se
trouvait une famille de remplacement ou
un cercle laïque doit être tous des
photos que c'est mais qui est qui et
quand même soit mieux que ce qu'est ce
que c'est que certaines personnes
avaient avant donc en sortir c'est assez
difficile puis la sortir pour aller où
cc il n'y a pas d'autres exemples de des
djihadistes et à la syrie soit revenant
lit-on sur son coupé leur famille veut
plus en parler ils peuvent plus trouver
d'emploi il n'y a pas de potes
perspective puis les seuls qui seraient
prêts à les accueillir mais c'est leur
groupe
l'état islamique ou deux donc il ya
vraiment cet enjeu l'aude qui est pas
facile parce que c'est des gens qui ont
déjà participé à des violences terribles
de tendre la main à ces personnes là
quand surviennent des rockets
comme une balance aussi le public veut
que les gens qui ont commis des crimes
soient jugés pour seul mais on a
beaucoup qui vont avoir dans le parcours
de réflexion plutôt en prison justement
c'est le cercle vicieux qui décède son
nom en lui même le pire mais c'est
important qui a aidé des services
appropriés le pont les accompagner en
prison
d'autres dangers mais donc ça se tasse
et le port pour revenir de noeuds dans
un engagement extrêmement c'est
difficile et l'oas et faut faire le
deuil de beaucoup de choses faut faire
le deuil de certitudes aussi s'est
défaussé c'est rassurant d'avoir une
explication qui peut continuer pense
qu'il va tout régler
revenez en arrêter plus de deux heures
c'est pas est ce que en fait j'ai trouvé
qu'est ce qu'on va faire des erreurs
c'est s'est très c'est ça peut être
douloureux parcours pythie il m'étonne
qu'on parle de radicalisation mettant
d'utiliser la violence pour justement
pour faire valoir sur une religion ou
s'ils défendent ou du mouvement
d'extrême-droite qui ticket qui sont les
fondements raciste et de nos points de
vue si facile de de condamner sans
disant betclic et lycées des eaux et
sont mauvaises méthodes mais
et dans les commettants de mouvements
d'extrême gauche si on veut le t6 à mon
avis à mon sens plus difficile à
critiquer puis plus difficile à trancher
une ligne entre ou est-ce que là où est
ce que le mouvement devient extrême
parce que les causes mettons qu'on parle
du féminisme ou anti racistes ces causes
leçons sont bonne saison sont
importantes sont valables sur qui comme
n'importe quoi dans son extrême si
jamais ce jeu mais bon là l'epita des
fois mais certaines personnes vont comme
dans n'importe quelle cause verser no 6
dans cette extrême le pilat à manier
le toit en tant que personnes qui
supportent est reconduite dit mais tu
attends minutes le jeu peut pas
poursuivre le tir peut pas aller jusque
là avec toi non mais je suis pour la
cause puisque ce désir mais si tu me
suis pas au dépôt vraiment pour la cause
pilotent
ça crie ça crée un espèce d'effet
d'entraînement vers cette extrême là
parce que c'était des pousses extrême
était partie du problème oui
c'est intéressant
c'est bien cognitif le sec mais on s'est
un peu de
paris le dernier au cerveau il ya
des enjeux complexes qu'il ya des choses
qu'on n'arrive pas nous même apercevoir
d'emblée puis on se fait on se fait
prendre puis entre autres la
polarisation vers les extrêmes c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est un peu une
tendance naturelle si vous allez dans
une assemblée où dans un débat à sévir
les positions pour cristalliser vers les
deux poules le plus extrême donc si le
ton on était ici l'eau avec le juge et
pieter serry dans le temps du projet
turcot cantine ont lancé les assemblées
mon
tavel représentants du mtq qui dit non
faut faire le plus le projet y a pas
d'autre façon vous connaissez rien c'est
ça puis
tu avais déjà qu'ils aient mon nom il
faudrait abattre de l'autoroute dufferin
un boulevard urbain et puis des
monorails par claude pierre
puis c'était les options qui étaient sur
la table c'est la plupart des résidences
verte issue mais était pas
une idée là aussi radical de
transformation urbaine et jean savary en
temps on était on n'est pas des pigeons
danis on n'est pas des spécialistes
transport non plus dans un camion
routier où est-ce qu'ils vont penser
c'est juste faudrait que ça soit pas
démolir la moitié du quartier pour
construire une autoroute plus grosse
mais les positions se
seraient pas les risques c'est normal
puisque ce que tu décris c'est assez
classique lui non il faut aller jusqu'au
booth non on ne va tout perdre ces
femmes 1 ces puits c'est donc il faut
c'est tout un travail sur nous mêmes
pour garder des positions nuancées quand
les débats seront sont polarisées c'est
vers un portable sur la question le
désert des idéaux d'extrême gauche qui
sont
basés sur la tradition humaniste
démocrate dans un sens le large
c'est sûr que ça rejoint peut-être c'est
plus facile à intégrer dans le cadre
démocratique
québécois dans les valeurs démocratiques
le vivent ensemble l'égalité sociale
égalité des chances et il s'est plus
proche de ce que la hiérarchie raciale
ou des éléments jeunes théocratique
comme ça donc c'est c'est
pour ça que c'est toujours délicate et
on n'essaie pas de on veut pas
faire comme je dis on n'est pas une
police de la pensée
les
bibliothèques d'idées qui peuvent
légitiment qui pourraient exprimer la
ligne la trace à la violence mais dans
certains cas la violence à voir
s'exprimer dès les discours d'elle le
donc si vous faites une manifestation
pacifique avec des symboles et un nul en
dix ans
faux faux que tel le groupe ethnique
s'en aille mais l'on n'est pas dans la
non violence qu'on n'est pas dans le
vivant semble vraiment c'est là où est
la nuance dans l'utilisation de la
violence là par exemple la position est
la même on voit
quand on en vient même pour des idéaux
égalitaires à
justifier la violence a justifié des
meurtres sa belle heures le centre
depuis le lancement de la société je
pense pour vous dire non lors on va
trouver d'autres façons d'exprimer ses
idées là un bios repense aux mouvements
d'extrême gauche les quatre pelés
les endroits où ces mouvements là on
était au pouvoir maintenant bien des cas
ça a été des régions très violent parce
que je voulais transformer l'ensemble la
société il y avait identifié des groupes
qui étaient ennemis de cette
transformation la contre lequel vient de
durance souvent très très brutal qui a
été appliquée donc c'est cette dynamique
là qu'on essaie de déconstruire pour
pouvoir acheter ces idées là mais
qu'elle s'exprime de façon à ce qu'ils
acceptent la nuance puis le le débat
démocratique soins puis c'est une
impression cd bob c'est une immense loeb
ce débat démocratique sans lui et il
sait plus rare où on le remarque juste
plus a toujours été comme ça
quelque chose
bon ça c'est une grande question je
pense pas être ça m'a placé pour
répondre à
cette grande question c'est sûr que bon
il ya vraiment à plusieurs facteurs le
lait on a parlé des des réseaux sociaux
le fait que
les informations circulent va très vite
les débats seront très vite les
réactions sont très vite
tout le monde peut prendre des positions
peut créer un contenu
un peu très vite donc il y aura
probablement qu'il près dé
contribuer à plus de réactivité moins de
réflexion le un terme
bon il ya des aspects positifs aussi
nougat ce que tout le monde puisse
s'exprimer c'est plus difficile aussi
pour des des
tentatives autoritaire de s'imposer là
parce que tout le monde rêve peut réagir
plus vite yoyo vraiment ça va dans tous
les sens mais bon c'est ça l'extrémisme
est pas nouveau je sais pas
depuis le 19e siècle le sait mais
c'est ça se transforme
mais c'est soit le format des questions
admettons que
jamais parlé un petit peu tôt mais
j'aimerais qu'on rentre un petit peu
plus en profondeur dans comment est-ce
qu'on peut aider quelqu'un dans notre
entourage parce que je pense c'est
vraiment l'essentiel tient en ce moment
c'est d'essayer de reconnaître les
signes avant coureurs qu'on ne discute
un plan tôt mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut
aider plus c'est quoi les outils qu'on a
cessé on parle un petit peu tantôt des
façons d'interagir mme yade sur autre
chose à faire est tué mais c'est sûr
c'est un jeu vraiment difficile vous
acceptez que
réussir pas pour tout le monde non plus
l'extrémisme a toujours existé puisse
avoir cessé d'exister là on a toutes les
idées qu'on a les listes d'un logis déjà
qui peut les pousser à des niveaux
étaient les limites ça fait partie un
peu de la vie
[Musique]
pour travailler ce soir lire des trucs
au niveau individuel personnel avec
notre entourage qu'on peut faire donc on
en a parlé reste à l'écouté garder les
pentes
garder la porte ouverte à tout le moins
le des fois on peut dire ben non là
c'est trop pour moi mais si tu si jamais
tu es parler d'autre chose je suis là
mais il ya des ressources aussi le qui
existent
le sens thann et un viol la clinique
polarisation aussi au centre ouest qui
pour les gens dans un parc contre
radicalisation qui ont des enjeux de
santé mentale peuvent
offrir du soutien
donc il ya des ressources qui existent
pour faire des démarches comment
d'accompagnement
des personnes puis de leur entourage le
pour poser de cheminée c'est un travail
de longue haleine mais c'est possible
vous faut toujours garder l'idée que
sepa sepa sepa si jamais perdu mais
perdu ouais c'est ça parce que j'imagine
qu'il y en a qui doivent
avoir des creusements des deuils à vivre
de laisser quelqu'un à lille c'est
quelqu'un que tu aimes quelqu'un qui
était mettons qu'on prend l'exemple du
de la crise la crevette actuellement à
dire ou es ce que
j'ai entendu des histoires de quelqu'un
qui était super en bons termes avec
toute sa famille avec ses proches le qui
depuis que là à cause de cette histoire
là où durant cette histoire là il ya
quelque chose qui se la payer quelque
chose qui est allé chercher cette
personne vraiment profondément puis le
sait son entourage qu'ils l'aiment qui
aiment cette personne là se sentent
complètement impuissant devant la
situation c'est sûr que j'imagine que
man pour les pour les proches des
personnes vasque alizés et ces gens là
ont besoin du support aussi parce que
c'est un deuil à faire oui tout à fait
tout à fait on offre des groupes de
soutien pour les pour les proches des
adhérentes est rude complot c'est une
demande qui a été fait par des gens qui
appelait au centre donc ça c'est un
service que nous on peut offrir
parce que souvent de partager
l'expérience avec d'autres qui vivent la
même chose ça permet de
rationaliser un peu la situation puis de
2 des traumatismes pour ne voir aussi
l'enjeu l'importance des
contextes sociopolitiques est vraiment
majeurs soit quand la situation change
mais nous avons un autre portrait une
fois on dit toujours après la copie de
sa pensée va y arriver un jour là mais
c'est quand ça sera plus au centre des
débats politiques pineau tensions
sociales
ça ça risque de d'ouvrir des
possibilités pour bien des gens pour
bien des familles
parce que ça va être possible de parler
d'autre chose rendu noir ses métiers
comme la moitié de nouvelles mauvaises
nouvelles un nouveau variant de vérité
dans les proches dans le prochain
mortiers comme la majorité des mesures
qui sont censés comment il va qu'on peut
imaginer que les gens qui étaient leurs
combos une fois qu'ils ont pu grand
chose à combattre ils vont devoir un
petit peu survireuse ballotté oui il ya
un profond distincts et les gens les
militants qui sont actifs qui était
actif dans d'autres mouvements avant que
verdi ou qui sont radicalisées danse
dans ce mouvement là mais qui vont
pouvoir porter cette
énergie là dans d&co structure puis une
majorité de sympathisants de cesser ces
mouvements là qui
vont vous peuvent garder leur adhésion
peuvent être essayés anti vaccins ou
mon amour des idées populistes qui
restent mais bon plus nécessairement le
seul mobiliser activement
insulter les juin 16 sociaux pour sa de
16 c c'est cela l'enjeu avec les crises
et que ça accroît le bassin est le thème
d'un militant très actif l'aude et des
mouvements extrémistes
puis c'est pour ça que mon des militants
qui était très actif auparavant le seul
essai crise lancé pour recruter d'ordino
de l'adhérent pour promouvoir en place
dès le sur le long terme une gui qui
sont pas nécessairement liés à la
covenant qui y vont c'est beaucoup plus
large c'est pour ça qu'on voit avec le
convoi des camionneurs des caméras
l'e-mail
les
l'allègement des mesures puis le
durcissement du temps des autorités
savent a
vu que ça ça fait quitter un parti de
manifestants mais il reste un noyau qui
s'est pas les mesures en tant que tel
qui qui qui les motive c'est une volonté
de changer le système politique de façon
plus influent plus radicale et est
seulement c'est ça va être plus d enjeu
stratégique qu'est ce qu'ils vont sera
pilier ou pas mais ils ne seront pas
convaincus par la levée des mesures
sanitaires donc mais dans la majorité
des cas c'est ça aussi le plein des
strings gouvernement
fonctionne puisque après salako vide
devient un virus comme les autres qui
arrive des fois qui est désagréable mais
pas plus que ça mais progressivement
vont pouvoir passer à d'autres choses
puis essayer de réparer les cicatrices
les cra laissez s'il me semble que c'est
bien certain que ça va être des ponts
qui vont être difficiles à reconstruire
le sais parce que juste
j'ai un exemple proche de moi d'un
grand-père d'un juge un but qui a envoyé
chez son grand père parce qu'ils
demandaient
d'aller chercher son vaccin si vous
voulez rentrer chez eux c'est le genre
la ford qui étoffe à reconstruire le
tissu ton grand-père
de tout arrêter après c'est parce que
c'était pas si ce n'est pas quelqu'un
qui était conflictuelle envers son grand
père c'est juste la crise actuelle a
fait lui c'est allé le chercher vraiment
profondément dans son son droit à la
liberté peu importe
qu'est ce qu'on entend par semaine c'est
sûr que quand ça va terminer et puis
plus le
même tu peux tu pu reprendre ta vie mais
tu peux pas d envoyer chier ton grand
père
enfin m peux tu peux excuser pis si le
grand père peut faire la distinction
entre la personne puis la bulle où il ya
derrière des idées extrémistes qui ont
fait avoir des comportements
violent
lola s'est passé mais c'est
effectivement c'est pas c'est pas
évident à
l'escaladé dans les mêmes termes et au
delà des périodes comme l'est et la
coved métier mettons en cause des crises
économiques ou en creux des outils de
hulu ou de béton de société ou est ce
qui est plutôt pauvre pauvreté est ce
qui est segmenté contexte
socio-économique mettons plus difficile
augmente les chances de réalisation
signée panorama n'est pas nécessairement
c'est ce qu'ils ont longtemps les études
avant l'heure avant le 11 septembre
dans le domaine c'est vraiment le cas en
avant bien après c'est ce qu'on voit
avec la cofidis avait la même chose mais
il ya les les principales tendances là
pour aborder l'extrémisme violent
c'était soit
lorgnette contre terroristes donc on
essaie de comprendre les réseaux les
financements les relations d'armes puis
dans des modèles aussi tu es comme les
mouvements de l'irl en irlande du nord
des groupes armés avec une hiérarchie
avec des financements des armes qu'ils
commettaient des échos spylo donc puis
on essayait politiquement devoir c'est
ce que stratégiquement on peut négocier
aussi où ça puis avait tout un courant
d'études sûr c'est de trouver les causes
profondes de l'engagement puis souvent
c'était la lorgnette socio économique
était importante vous avez ouais les
catholiques en irlande dans son versant
sont marginalisés est tout sauf pour
ceux qui ceux qui se révoltent et puis
en donnant d'ailleurs égalité on on
arriverait on
préviendra le terrorisme comme ça en
faisant des concessions terre-plein ce
soit quand même qu'en transformant le
système
sera du compte en étudiant vraiment les
adhérents aux mouvements extrémistes
violents particulier que c'est pas
nécessairement
la motivation principale
ça va être ça va être ça va jouer dans
le sentiment marginal a sion le
sentiment de
d'exclusion investissez on parle plus de
privations relative c'est à dire si vous
n'avez pas ce que vous considérez que à
temps pour faire la france si vous
n'avez pas ce à quoi vous considérez
avoir droit
au plan des perspectives au plan
économique au plat du respect au plan de
la place en société là vous allez être
plus susceptibles
d'attirer par des idées extrémistes qui
ont rejeté le blâme sur l'argent de la
société
donc s'il par exemple si on prend le
code et des militants djihadistes dans
les pays occidentaux
la grande partie de ses militants à la
vienne des
communautés migrantes deux pays au
moyen-orient l'afrique du nord 2-0
mais c'est pas les immigrés eux-mêmes ce
soit les deuxièmes les gens deuxième
génération
qui sont mieux et égérie sont nés ici
ils ont la citoyenneté ils ont ils envie
vont à l'école comme tout le monde ils
ont tous les droits mais rendue à
l'adolescence comment savoir que c'est
ce soit sur papier mais c'est pas
toujours le code en réalité
que ce soit il ya la discrimination ils
sont pas considérés par par tout le
monde comme des citoyens à part entière
s'ils veulent pratiquer une religion ça
se prépare bien vu
alors que économiquement matériellement
ils sont beaucoup mieux lotis que leurs
parents qui ont immigré qui ont vécu des
difficultés que ce soient eux aussi
attendaient à ces difficultés lors
c'était il me grey pour donner un
meilleur meilleur avenir à leurs enfants
ou pour améliorer les conditions mais il
était prêt à subir ce etc ces bus et
brimades alors que
la légende deuxième génération
estimé avec raison d'avoir droit aux
mêmes
ou même perspective que la populaire est
la population et quand c'est parce qu'on
perçoit on a l'impression que ce n'est
pas le cas ben c'est là qu'on est poussé
vers la la marginalisation qui la
radicalisation la même chose avec les
mouvements d'extrême droite en europe et
en afrique du nord ça souvent été
considéré comme étant bon une réaction à
la mondialisation à la le changement
économique le néolibéralisme qui a mené
plus de difficultés pour
la classe ouvrière
en occident mais quand on regarde les
adhérents c'est pas vraiment ce profil
démographique le mais c'est un profil
qui pensent que à terme il va voir un
déclin social économique culturel
de leur groupe qui voit un peu le monde
dans lequel ils
prenaient pour acquis se transformer et
ils pensent qu'ils vont perdre quelque
chose là dedans
c'est sur vous ben un peu les mouvements
17 extrême le mouvement nationaliste
québécois d'un plus son velouté on veut
préserver totem la langue de culture du
sun mais qui mais quand il fallait
arrêter des gens qui adhèrent mois - le
premier maintenant ou souverainistes
mais peu extrême mais c'est quand que ça
devient tellement on vient sa remise en
dise et c'est lui qui le dit oui oui bah
c'est ça s'il satisfait que c'est
l'europe que pas de l'espace dans le
dans la société démocratique qui dans
les structures qui existent pour
exprimer la volonté de changement qui
que l'on va aller vers les armes dans le
mouvement souverainiste est relativement
petit le ceux qui veulent prendre
décembre pour l'instant mais par le
passé
donc donc effectivement c'est ça donc
c'est vraiment le met effectivement dans
des moments de crise
économique sociale
l'extrémisme
flurry la crise des années 30
puis la montée du fascisme en europe il
ya un lien clair parce que les crises
déstabilise l'ordre dans lequel on est
remettre en cause des choses qu'on
prenait pour acquise contre la copie
c'est un bon exemple
essayant des moteurs aussi de de
l'extrémiste donc car les on a remarqué
que les sociétés humaines donc
en bien ou en mal c'est sont capables de
tolérer de supporter des situations très
difficiles inégalitaire
si les gens estiment que lui un ordre
social qui est
relativement légitime
pendant longtemps les
jeux c'est encore le cas dans certains
pays les paysannes en avant un produit
superbe
avons une agriculture de subsistance bon
tu sortes de privations des
régimes autoritaires se
met vont pas nécessairement se révolter
s'il considère pas qu'il ya un ordre
social qui est qui est affecté ou que
ils ont pas que leur sort est illégitime
donc c c'est donc ceci de façon large
dit c'est pas la pauvreté ou le
la privation en tant que tel qui crée
volonté révolté c'est le sentiment de ne
pas avoir
de
que ce soit lors des choses soit
illégitime c'est curieux quand même
parce que tu es le sentiment dans
certains cas on pourrait se dire il
serait très légitime
tandis que dans d'autres dans d'autres
que quiconque va plus avoir ce sentiment
le quinqua en réalité ces petits pas du
tout
persécutés ou été éliminés oui merci
sauf pour ceux qui on parle de
sentiments le puits des voix la solution
ça devrait te décides de
déconstruire cette perception là mais il
ya toujours une faune légitime à ce
sentiment là ça déçoit
ce n'est pas nécessairement la situation
qui est objectivement qu'il discrimine
qui discrimine cette personne là mais
souvent des façons de mener certains
discours certains débats qui
qui vont exclure ou mettre de côté sa
certes un certain sentiment
et la
cc lacq il faut travailler ça par
exemple dans on voit beaucoup de
temps dans le milieu de recherche sur
l'extrémisme ya beaucoup d'intérêts sur
mouvement misogyne violent mais violent
ou plus ou moins violents me soit c'est
en ligne nommé et on se rend compte
c'est beaucoup des jeunes hommes qui à
terre qui ont l'impression que bon le
féminisme que le ou
les avancées au plan de la diversité
sexuelle que ça leur enlève quelque
chose si on fait des recherches
objectivement du palco vraiment sympa on
voit pas les le fait que y ait plus de
femmes embauchées dans les positions de
pouvoir ça discrimine pas les hommes
c'est un
réparation d'une égalité au fait que les
hommes étaient embauchés par défaut par
le passé
mais il ya une façon dans les deux
probablement dans
l'éducation sur la diversité sexuelle
sur le vieux nice sur la façon dont
s'est présenté à certains jeunes hommes
qui font faire en sorte que ils
perçoivent comme étant une attaque
contre leur identité même compte
non ce sont des choses qui peuvent pas
changer d'horizon pour choisi et c'est
pour ça qu'ils vont
que certains vont vouloir se révolter
vont adhérer à des des idées violente
autour de ces enjeux
donc c'est assez délicat ja on veut pas
le principe pas de dire de ce1 ce2
de faire l'éducation sur le genre sur la
diversité sexuelle sur le féminisme jeu
terrasse est objectivement c'est une
bonne chose qu'il ya une plus grande
ouverture y ait plus de
diversité puisqu'elle y est on en sait
ce qu on en parle depuis que ça soit
nepean vraie égalité qu'elle se soit agi
sans que tout le monde puisse vivre
selon
tout selon son identité c'est très
important
mais la marge à le faire puis
d'inclure tout le monde que ce soit
quelque chose qu'ils soient portés
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient au quotidien
qu'ils soient vécues le ça pose d'autres
sortes de défis qui sont qui restent à
relever c'est ça parce que quelques en
parlais tantôt de sentiment
d'appartenance
souvent c'est que les gens ils semblent
pas ils sont pas que dans l'enseignement
comme tu dis dans la société comme on la
vit maintenant s'en sentent pas que ça
les rejoindront celles là qui vont
chercher
sa tenue importance avec d'autres mondes
qu'il l'a leurs idéaux les rejoindront
3,5 mais ça c'est le travail
d'inclusion pour essayer d'aller
rejoindre vraiment tout le monde pour
que tout le monde cendres qui
appartiennent à la société
non radicale moutons
j'imagine c'est extrêmement difficile
parce qu'il
en fait est ce que c'est possible parce
que c'est ça ressemble s'assemble
extrêmement c'est pas le mât pas
possible dit il
ya pas de nous on va pas éviter les
débats corse il ya des mois il ya déjà
des positions qui sont tranchées puis il
faut faut en débattre il faut il faut
exprimer fort les exprimer donc
forcément on va déplaire déjà forcément
il ya des gens qui vont sentir
attaqué
lors de bien conscient le qu'on peut pas
c'est tout tout tout aplanir pierre oui
mais peut-être mais tous ces c c'est sûr
que yoyo il ya vraiment
il n'ya pas de solution le miracle là
dessus le pis pour sa part jacques allix
l'extrémisme pas toujours existé
guillaume aussi un moyen de faire la
plupart des débats de façon relativement
apaisé qui soit pour personnaliser
qu'ils soient qui vise pas les individus
en tant que tel qui vise les idées
seulement que soit plus factuelle pour
qu'on débatte vraiment des idées
vraiment des bons étrangers sur des
faits
si on veut parler de
d'inclusion on va amener les données on
va amener les les données sur les
toute
l'ascension sociale sur
le sentiment de sécurité sur terra puis
à partir de là on voit on on peut
établir des politiques qui vont
adresser les problèmes de façon
[Musique]
notre roi tant que possible ouais mais
cette image in que cette
ça ça fait tellement du sens de dire on
va évaluer toutes les situations d'un
point de vue neutre avec des données
puis avec des bacs et par des études ces
choses là mais j'imagine que
c'est que cette idée là si tu pars avec
la prémisse que le système est et comme
toi le stemi campus cette neutralité
l'eau devient pu noter que c'est le jeu
ma gêne que devient le problème qui va
rester toujours
la radicalisation oui bah ça faux faux
faux coeur
tout le monde puisse sentir qu'il ya une
écoute au moins que au moins en tant que
personne n'attend que quelques individus
ils ont leur place les personnes qui ont
un cap à sa place
même peut-être que ses idées sont
tellement à l'ouest que personne jamais
qui va les accepter
c'est assez frustrant c'est
avec avec ce qui s'est passé avec le
clivage complet avec les idées pendant
que vides c'est que peut-être qu'un
groupe qui a senti que leur idée était
pas du tout entendu pas du tout écouter
puis le c'est peut-être là que ça a
contribué à radicaliser encore plus ce
groupe là qui faisait en gros on avait
des des questionnements légitimes qu'ils
font comme le manioc riz oui mais ils
sont donc là
je vous reprends
indexer le aucun dirigeant aucune
autorité là
c'est pas mon rôle mais il ya vraiment
un travail à faire pour
accepter différents points de vue d'une
part puis surtout accepter les gens qui
les portent les airs que si
si vous arrivez pour dire bon y'en a pas
de pandémie c'est
c'est une invention pour quatre hommes
restent aux points soit soit mis dehors
c'est un complot des démocrates avec les
juifs puis avec tel autre groupe
objectivement n'y a pas vraiment de
place pour débattre c'est faux
ça n'existe pas mais si vous dites non
regardez le coc vidyo le coucou qui
disent ah
ben là non seulement la personne en
pension au point de vue entendu ce qui
est quand même normal le moins
professionnel mais là personne ne sait
pas quelle autre place sont en tant que
tel il est mis de côté puis bin là
pas vraiment moyen d'aller ramener cette
personne là dans le débat démocratique
factuel vous l'avez à d'emblée exclu
donc c'est vraiment ou à ce niveau là qu
on le souvent échappé pendant la partie
c'est ça et parce que c'est pas la
responsabilité individuelle
oui mais il ya quand même la gestion
politique à faire pour pour éviter la
radicalisation
tout le monde semble que sa place dans
ce site oui absolument c'est un travail
constant puis à tous les niveaux des
gouvernements au niveau local les
institutions d écoles d un peu toutes
les institutions donc dans l'inclusion
dans
le respect
le vivre ensemble c'est vraiment
ce qu'on essaie de travailler au centre
le sait que ce soit quelque chose qui
soit agi sans qu'ils soient au quotidien
d'un peu tous nos échanges donc on peut
savoir puis donc après ça l'idée est
idéaliste mais c'est que après ça les
débats d'idées pour les devants pour
s'exprimer
parce que les
tout le monde va appartenir à la
collectivité aux sociétés
donc après on est plus à l'aise on est
plus beau exprimer nos idées pierre
débattre parce qu'on sait que on débat
de notre personne au dépôt pas de notre
légitimité en tant qu'être humain mais
plus d'une idée qui sont apparus depuis
qu'on peut déconstruire qu'on peut
débattre comment est ce qu'il ya eu des
conversations et je pense sincèrement
entre le centre puis le gouvernement
mais ce que des conversations autour de
ceux de ce que tu sais au gouvernement
des conversations autour de la
radicalisation de comment traiter ces
différents points de vue là où ça a été
sa peau était sur la table ça a
certainement été sur la table parce que
bon c'est bon c'est que c'est une
préoccupation des gouvernements
le ministre à la sécurité publique au
québec a commandé plusieurs études à des
chercheurs sur les mouvements
complotistes pour essayer de comprendre
ce que c'est comprendre les fondements
les moyens de prévention donc c'est une
préoccupation qui est là et on
on on n'est pas dans le secret des dieux
mais quand on voit les communications de
l'évolution mais on voit que yo des
essais on essaie de voir qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont fonctionner
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont radicaliser par
exemple au départ des campagnes de
vaccination parlait beaucoup de
vaccin vaccin on a progressivement
changé vers
le terme et citations vaccine à la sauce
a permis de regarder les raisons pour
lesquelles différentes personnes ne
voulaient pas se faire avec ce festival
des corps j'hésite
décortiqué dire que il y en a qui
pensent que les vaccins c'est mauvais
c'est comme cécile du poison ça va les
tuer
toutes sortes d'autres d'autres théories
il ya 1 heure qui adhèrent
d'aidé soit des mouvements de médecine
alternative qui vont très bien non on
préfère se se guérir avec les connaissez
des produits naturels parce que ce qui
est en laboratoire dont on sait pas
exactement
d'où ça vient ça enrichit les grosses
pharmaceutique on n'a pas vraiment
besoin de ça il ya l'immunité naturelle
tout ça il y en a d'autres qui on parle
carrément des vaccins il y en a d'autres
que c'est qu'ils perçoivent comme des
interdits religieux il ya un autre qui
tant qu'ils n'ont pas besoin qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin que subban en garde
je pourrais être malade puis ce sera
pire puis à face au sein concerne un
pote qui ont fait en arrière toute cette
palette là mais on peut
prendre en compte des questionnements
qui sont légitimes des idées des crimes
qui sont légitimes il ya personne qui
soit fixe
dans ok
c'est vrai que des effets secondaires
c'est vrai que les vaccins ils sont
pas tous pareils aucun débat
n'est pas d'abord à voir mais il ya
comme des pions la scientifique qui qui
est qui qui existent pique quand on peut
pas occulter même si difficile d'amener
des nuances le comme ça au plan
scientifique dans le débat public
c'est quelque chose qui est important
parce que c'est au delà de prog menthe
et le nombre de personnes vaccinées il
ya toute la question de la confiance
envers les institutions envers le
système de santé envers la santé
publique envers la science en général
qui devra aller à plus long terme donc
si on met par exemple des obligations
d'accidents depuis qu'on a déjà sauvé sa
vacciner même si elles seront pas
convaincus oui on parle de toi bon ça
peut vacciner contre la copie mais est
ce qu'ils font jour on voit les verts
avec snailhouse enfin la nasse où la
rougeole demain peut-être pas si six ans
que le sida mais est plus répressifs que
qu'accueillait ben
ça risque de miner la confiance envers
les autorités vont
parler le des facteurs
radicalisation la confiance envers dont
le système en général mais les
institutions la démocratie c'est quelque
chose qui est aussi fondamentale si on
n'a pas l'impression que
que les systèmes d'éducation que
la science au caire que c'est légitime
que ça fonctionne que c'est à notre
service donc ça aussi on pense que ça
sert dos aux intérêts l'on risque d'être
plus attentifs à des a des idées
extrémistes
est tout le temps dans l'accueil fut
inventé depuis plus en parle depuis
tantôt c'est comme le mot-clé ont dressé
des dans le tendre et justement l'autre
le 71 puis tentelier
exemple que je trouve il le frappe
antilles mais ton team et ont une pensée
d'extrême droite racistes par exemple
tpiy le une migraine réussite qui se
retrouve confronté à du racisme moati a
tous eu ça augmente ses chances
de se radicaliser le team parce que s'il
ya ce sentiment d'exclusion le puits le
psy lui comme un acte volant viola sags
menthe le sag la serbe le racisme de
l'autorité d'une radicalisation en
engendre une autre puis chacun se chacun
scan d'un bord des piscines comme sa
faction peu juste comme ça
c'est ça la brouille facile à dire comme
ça mais on peut juste comme se parler se
retrouver dans le milieu un peu et puis
cette seconde langue on évite bédié est
en tout cas tu parlais même exemple
même scénario au jdd
mais je passe de tête référence au
mouvement et une scène aux côtés de
misogyne
masculin et y
avons peut-être des fois t'es site est
outillée entendre des propos mettant de
d'une féministe que ils vont trouver
radical cavalli puskar en paix dans leur
position leur position voit votre
foi que l'autre côté on va encore plus
capé contre aux autres pays au final si
on si on s'entendait un petit peu plus
pis même si évidemment que les idées les
idées sont pas toutes égales le dise on
peut tout aussi aussi bonne qui aussi
fondé sur l'idée de donner eux-mêmes
des capable de d'avoir pu l'empathie
pour l'humain derrière c'est comme si le
combat qu'on est victime ce qui valait 3
e mail
les
familles là le djihadisme l'extrême
droite s'est déjà plaint d'être là
dessus le son que les deux mouvements se
nourrissant poulain l'autre donc et
depuis le lait les attentats du 11
septembre puisque ça beaucoup nourri
l'imaginaire
de l'islam
fait basculer certaines
certaines personnes qui étaient plutôt
libérale vers des formes d'extrême
droite populiste en disant que l'islam
steak c'était un soluble dans la
démocratie dans les sociétés
occidentales mais là en voyant arriver
des immigrés
de confession musulmane
voit ces personnes doivent à travers
cette lorgnette là donc il ya une
confrontation mais ça ça sent venir
l'exemple des initiales aussi est bon
parce que c'est
bon c'est des gens qui sont
très mal maîtrisé
comme tu as de blague la ligne ces sites
bon ton de taper sur cette communauté
qui est assez diversifié il ya eu des
codes violence puis les discours super
violeur ou au sein de ces communautés là
mais il s'est beaucoup des gens qui sont
des gens qui d'abord ce sont malheureux
c'est seul le noeud du problème tient à
se moquer d'eux diabète c'est parce que
t'es trop nul tout ce que je vais
quitter comme ça mais on attend du
problème
en fout final quelqu'un qui se
radicalise qui
vient d'écossé tsé tsé
c'est quelqu'un qui se sent pas bien où
quelqu'un qui manque quelque chose il ya
des besoins qui sont répandues par
l'engagement radical qu'ils sont pas
parlés son entourage par la société dans
laquelle je vis est clair quels sont les
services que vous offrez au centre quels
sont les recours les bons on a un
travail à tous les niveaux de
préparation le donc la prévention on
utilise un modèle de santé publique n'a
trop niveau prévention primaire en fait
la prévention l'ensemble dans l'ensemble
la population ont fait des webinaires de
formation sur des enjeux qui touchent la
radicalisation on diffuse des recherches
des guides à destination de la
population fait d'une intervention
médias plus on dépense comme on fait des
podcasts ont fait
même
nouvelle réalité pour moi mais on fait
ça
on fait aussi des
formations spécifiques donc où ça qu'on
dit secondaire pour des milieux
spécifiques qui travaillent au contact
de gens qui ont des parcours de
radicalisation ou qui pourraient n'avoir
éducateurs travailleurs de première
ligne d'avants sociaux
journalisme m donc on fait des
formations sur demande l'information au
service au québec sont gratuits pour des
demandes de formation
de d'accompagnement et toutes sortes
et on travaille en accompagnement on
appelle accompagnement communautaire
c'est à dire qu'on va travailler soit
avec des personnes qui ont parcours de
radicalisation ou leur entourage proche
mois la famille soit leur milieu de
travail école
donc bons pour des raisons évidentes
beaucoup de gens qui sont dans un
parcours de radicalisation pense pas
qu'ils auront besoin des devises qui
sont un problème sans savoir la vérité
mais c'est leur entourage qui a besoin
de les accompagner l'avenant et donc on
va outillés l'entourage est donc ce cd
avec des rencontres soit ce soit dans
les milieux soit à distance avec la
pandémie neige on a un service
d'accompagnement
qui m'ont qui peuvent répondre qu'ils
vont répondre au téléphone il ligne des
infos radical qui
pour des demandes d'assistance
les enjeux de radicalisation
et on va offrir d accompagnement
individualisé aux personnes qui en ont
besoin je sais pas longtemps c'est bien
sûr plus sur base volontaire
on a aussi un programme de mentorat
donc c'est des bénévoles qui sont formés
par le service d'accompagnement du
centre pour
bon passer du temps avec les personnes
radicaliser - cheminement de
désengagement
question de que ces gens là justement et
d'autres horizons et de partager des des
questionnements avoir quelqu'un qui
parlait parce que bon soutien des gens
qui sont dans des milieux radicaux à
part leur entourage extrémistes et
peut-être des policiers ou des
travailleurs sociaux ils ont pas au
grand nombre dans leur vie donc c'est
important d'avoir rude pour reconnecter
socialement donc ce programme là comme
j'en ai parlé on offre
des groupes de soutien pour les proches
d'adhérer aux théories du complot et on
va moduler ce soit nos services
d'accompagnement selon selon les besoins
c'est une base individuelle donc on
prend chaque corps selon ses besoins
parfois c'est juste un téléphone un peu
les broussailles et une situation avec
la famille des fois c'est ça peuvent
durer des années quelqu'un qui ait
besoin d'accompagnement c'est vraiment
selon les besoins donc en gros c'est ça
on a le service on a une équipe un axe
scientifiques non je suis directeur qui
supervise le contenu sur le plan
scientifique qui fait le pont entre la
communauté de recherche puis les minutes
pratiques qu'on est et en gros c'est pas
mal ça fait pas le tour fait
mobilisation communautaire aussi on est
présent
des tables de concertation quartiers
dans les villes un peu partout pour
mener de la sensibilisation pour être
présent pour faire connaître nos
services pour avoir tout un réseau de
partenaires aussi parce que souvent les
besoins c'est d'être mis en contact avec
donc une grotte donc si ça peut être des
gros [ __ ] travers de rue ça peut être
des maisons de jeunes des groupes
religieux
selon les besoins on ne développe plus
au maintien tout un réseau de
partenaires communautaires pour essayer
justement de réintégrer d'elie baup pas
de réintégrer on accompagne les gens
pour qu'ils se réintègrent
dans la société dans un environnement
qui soit pro sociale donc qui
composent ce qui le but c'est pas que de
deux
d'empêcher les gens de se mobiliser des
tranchées de vouloir changer les choses
c'est au contraire les accompagner puis
de le faire de façon démocratique mais
de façon pro sociale
super merci beaucoup merci à vous merci
merci
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
pataquès convient
oui
si vous voulez plus des contenus
excellent comme ce que vous venez
d'entendre aller sur le titre le pitch
vous abonner pour trop de leur part mme
otis outre au delà ouais trois pièces
par horace par mois et vous avez les pas
de carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis à
recruter les podcasts qu'ils allaient
avoir pouvoir avoir une avance quand
vous allez tirer la dynamique entre les
amis de tout le temps avec une avance
sur les jobs en avance mais entre deux
toits mais avec pétillante une avance
sur l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que le ch et le podcast fini voulu
nous en dire davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcasts etc là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
te filer nicole non nicoli pleut
maintenant comme un fils travaille la
place travot de taza taille est là mais
on jase on parle de conversion qu'on
m'aide à voir mais ce si vous voulez
avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pet ul il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous